занедбані будинки заколочені вікна майже
ніяких ознак життя але це лише на перший
погляд це територія кар'єрів бурого
вугілля я би розширити кар'єр на початку
ці населені пункти планувалося знести
втім Щось пішло не за планом і тепер тут
живуть українські біжівці
це невеличке село Мангейм тут же Ніхто
не чекає на автобус
час наче зупинився
раптова Злива підсилює відчуття
занедбаності та депресії
втім Попри це надія на краще майбутнє є
принаймні В сусідньому селі Моршині воно
теж закинути але туди поселили біженців
з різних країн
Володимир вже рахує години до зустрічі
зі своєю родиною дружина і четверо дітей
приїдуть з України завтра а поки основні
компаньйони чоловіка це інші біженці
Сирії Афганістану та Албанії
всі разом біженці живуть у цьому будинку
це чоловічий гуртожиток Володимир тут
мешкає з кінцями Минулого року
[музика]
з Вірменії ось тут він і Албанець
холостяцьке
найважливіше питання для чоловіка де
вони житимуть вже з родиною коли всі
приїдуть вони трохи боялися вони не вони
не знали Ну що якщо їх тут чекає буде
очікувати і вони якби ну
переживали жінка і зараз переживає от
відносно навчання тому що троє діток
школярів а
найменший в садочку і вона переживає Ну
як звідси добиратися та й Я також як
ну дітям бо це дуже важливе питання
надзвичайно ну в першу чергу для дітей
тут немає Ані аптек Ані магазинів Ані
лікарень треба їхати у сусіднє місто
дюрен за 12 кілометрів каже чоловік
олені на що не жаліється Ну що все рівно
в житті потрібно починати Я так ну
Ми звичайно вдячні владі Німеччини за
відношення заставлення таке тепле що є
підтримка і
всебічна підтримка в тому числі і
навчання будинки місцевих жителів у цих
селах навколо кар'єрів викупив
енергетичний концерн рве переселивши їх
в інші місця та виплативши компенсації
але як там опинилися
біженцію Они попадают так называется
коли біженці приїжджають до Німеччини
вони потрапляють до так званих пунктів
першого розподілу Таким чином люди які
зараз перебувають у цих селах отримали
розселення за квотою Комуни і прибули
відповідно туди і на місцях мер міста
еркеленс відповідно зобов'язаний людей
розселити
людей расселить и В этот момент и в цей
момент відбулася домовленість між
концерном рвє якому належить ці землі та
комуною еркелендс
те В якому будинку та хто з біженців
живе свідчать білі аркуші А4 з переліком
прізвищ розвішені на будинках Володимир
не єдиний українець у моршиніху є ще
кілька українських родин ця українка не
хоче показувати своє обличчя разом із
родиною вона вирвалася з одного з
окупованих Росією міст на півдні України
втім батьки і досі залишилися там родина
обживається на новому місці від суму та
депресії рятує вивчення німецької мови
всім в курсі що ви знаєте і депресувати
особу і ніколи
шприхан хьорин лезен Ми вчимося якось
так знаєте вже вечір можна вийти
поговорити подихати повітрям і знову
утром на курси так що з приходом курсів
в депресія якось знаєте відійшла на
другий план Ти спочатку була так
депресивно бо ми шукали себе тут
наука не скаржиться Головне що вдалося
виїхати з окупації в умовах гарні Умови
нормальні жити тут можна зовсім скоро ви
з'єднатися з родиною зможе і Володимир
Цілком можливо що вони будуть жити в
одному з будинків повз якими зараз
прогулюємося а поки про Україну тут
нагадують хіба що соняшники і за словами
Володимира гуркіт бойових літаків під
час літають літаки винищувачі трохи
такий
великий шум чуття такий гул як Таке
враження що що будуть бомбити Але що ж
буде з усіма біженцями та їхніми
родинами після розширення кар'єру
видобуток вугілля викликає тут постійні
протести екоактивістів за їх словами це
є недоцільним і сприяє кліматичній кризі
після численних дискусій розширювати
кар'єри таки передумали Німеччина
відмовилася від видобутку бурого вугілля
тож принаймні Це село Моршині змусити не
будуть а обіцяють зробити тут зону
відпочинку
як завершиться розробки у цьому
вугільному басейні оскільки кар’єри
величезні було ухвалено рішення зробити
з цього району так звану курортну зону
села майбутнього
для цього ці кар’єри будуть заповнені
водою буде озеро навколо якого стоять Ці
будинки Які на даний момент можливо
виглядають занедбаними
але якщо до цього прикласти руку то за
2-3 тижні вони виглядатимуть просто
чудово трава коситься паркани фарбуються
вони частина місцевих жителів вже
намагаються викупити свої будинки назад
цілком
можливо тою на землі майбутнього курорту
і замість покинутих цих села стануть
селами майбутнього замість безлюдних
доріг Тут будуть зелені сади але поки ці
села примари слугують безпечним
прихистком для українських біженців
перед їх Дорогою у нове життя